Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
says if you don't fight you can't win
she has become one of the Democrats
leading voices in Congress a recent poll
in New Hampshire shows Warren would be
the front-runner if that state's
Democratic presidential primary were
held today which would be a surprise to
New Hampshire voters she leads former
Vice President Joe Biden and Vermont
senator Bernie Sanders Warren's latest
book this fight is our fight the battle
to save America's middle class is out
today in paperback it accuses the
government of working for the wealthy
and corporations at the expense of
everyday Americans
senator Warner welcome Warren excuse me
welcome back before we get to the middle
class economy we have this North Korea
question there was a North Korean
official apparently coming to America
you said the president doesn't look like
he has a strategy but it looks like he's
calling off the summit last week seems
to have little fire under the North
Koreans that three hostages had been
released so maybe there is a strategy
you know look North Korea is a bad actor
we understand that and the president had
already promised that they could have a
meeting with the President of the United
States something that both Kim Jong Un's
father and grandfather had long long
sought then it's been back and it's been
forth I want this to work I want this to
work
to reduce the the threat to South Korea
to Japan to our allies in the region to
the United States of America to the
entire world but it really takes a
strategy and I look at the comparison
with China look at what China's doing
China's got the long term art and it's
playing everybody it's playing North
Korea it's playing South Korea it's
playing the United States of America
because it has a long time
whole-of-government strategy that keeps
driving toward it in at this point who
knows what's coming out of Washington
alone like I said I hope it all works to
John's point there does seem to be some
sort of a strategy that does appear to
be working because right now as we sit
here it looks like the talks are on for
well as we sit here and I hope it
happens I want to see it happen but you
can't take a bunch of disconnected dots
draw a line and say oh that must have
been a strategy because I can now draw a
line through them what it takes for a
stranded
is that you really have a goal you build
up the team to work on that goal you
know diplomacy is a long and difficult
task and it takes people who know what
they're doing the Trump administration
has decimated the State Department so
that the very people who are the experts
on the economy who are experts on the
language on the history who help
negotiate these deals in a way that's
going to protect the interests of the
United States many of those people
aren't even there you you say you want
this meeting to happen
you mean you trust the North Koreans you
believe that will ultimately
denuclearize what what I want to see is
I want to see this work if the goal
truly is let's see the North Koreans
give up their nuclear weapons of course
I want to see that and I hope that the
president is successful at that but that
there's a long space between here and
there and it takes a coherent and
executed strategy to get there and right
now it just looks like it's what's the
latest that occurred to the guy with the
thumbs early in the morning is there
anything that he's doing you know he
gets hammered by the Democrats
repeatedly is there anything that you
can see that he's doing that you can say
you know what he's doing a good job on
that well look it one thing he is doing
is he he gets in he tries to stir things
up that's good if you've got an
underlying plan that's what you really
want to see what are you aiming toward
and like I said you have to do this I'm
serious about this comparison with with
a country like China think about it this
way right now China is investing 9% of
its GDP in infrastructure roads bridges
power right it's building a future for
its economy for its workers it's it's
making that economy not only work today
but building it for the future in the
United States what are we doing we're
spending less than 3% of our GDP on
infrastructure while much of it crumbles
around us the consequence of that is
because the Trump administration gave
away a trillion and a half dollars in
tax
cuts there's no money there to add to
the infrastructure the way we need to do
to produce those good jobs today and to
help build a better environment for the
future
Sara Warren let me ask you a question
about democratic politics quickly
because David Wasserman of the cook
Political Report did this tally in the
65 Democratic primary so far with at
least one man and one woman and no
incumbent women defeated men at forty
five races men defeated women in 18
what's happening in the Democratic Party
listen women women are coming into their
own women are using their voices they're
getting in this fight and that's what it
should be I mean the title my book is
this fight is our fight and you better
believe it this is a time when two
things are changing at the same time the
first is that there is an attack on
democracy and this is something
Republicans have been pushing for a long
time on voting on an independent
judiciary attacks on a free press and at
the same moment democracy itself is
rewiring so that people are coming off
the sidelines they don't look at
democracy as something that well I vote
once every four years
people are stepping up including people
who are stepping up to run for office
who've never run for office before you
know I want to say I was a little ahead
of my time on this I never thought I was
going to be somebody who ran for all yes
I was I wanted to be a public school
teacher I ended up as a law professor I
was a policy wonk but people are
stepping up now to run for office to
help people who are running for office
they're in the game and I love it let me
ask you about your book which is an
argument for something okay now do
Democrats do you face a challenge which
is that a lot of people look at the
Democrats and they think they're just
against Trump in other words not for
something but against something how do
you make the case in an environment
where we have so much news happening so
fast where you have talked about an
assault on democracy which a lot of
Democrats say that's what you should be
talking about others say you should be
promoting something before something how
do you work out those two I got into
this fight long before Donald Trump was
anything other than the host of a
reality TV show I got into this because
I was watching
Amerika shift from a country that really
worked for working people a country that
was really about opening opportunities
an America that invested in kids like me
I went to a commuter college that cost
$50 a semester an opportunity that's not
out there for kids today and what I've
watched over time and what I talk about
in this book is how this country works
better and better for the corporate
interests for the executives for the
billionaires who have the money to
influence Washington to make it work for
them and as a result we're getting to be
a country that works better and better
for fewer and fewer and kicks dirt and
everybody else's face I'm in this to
fight back you know this is the good
part Elizabeth Warren 20 should they
start making up the bumper stickers yes
or no no yes or no no okay no later
Warren thank you so much to you